Savannah is in Charlotte
Hi Savannah how are you?
I'm good how are you, Dave?
Better than I deserve, what's up?
All right. So I'm 22 and
I'm about to start my first job out of college
The company is there's a lot of travel involved with the job
And the company
requires that I pay out of pocket
and then they reimburse me and they suggest I get a credit card
to pay those expenses first, but I don't want to do that.
So how should I work around that?
Um, do you have any money?
Yeah I do. I'm going into Baby Step 4.
Good. Good for you. Well done.
Well, um, how big of a company is it?
Um, it's a medium-sized
company. 250 employees
OK.
Well why don't you talk to someone in leadership
and explain to them that you don't borrow money
and I don't use credit cards
so I won't be getting a credit card
I really don't think it's right that
I'm using my money to travel for your company
And so um I'd like for you all to furnish me a
card. I don't think that'll work.
I want you to try it with humility
and kindness, not being a jerk about it
I'm not suggesting you do something to lose your job
or that you have an attitude or something
And just go, "Hey, I'm 22
"I just got out of college. I am not
"borrowing money. I'm not gonna get into debt.
"And so you guys gotta help me, OK?
"Cause I'm not taking out a credit card.
"Is there any way you could just furnish me a card?"
"Cause by the way, all this stuff I'm doing I'm doing for you."
"I'm not gonna put anything on the card that isn't company."
"And if I do you can fire me."
I don't think they'll do it. But I would ask. OK?
If that doesn't work,
then what we suggest to people is,
two other options. One is, get a different job.
Which is unreasonable, probably.
The second option is for you to get a
separate checking account just for travel.
Put a debit card on it and put
the amount in there that you need
for monthly travel expenses
And you only have to "prime the pump" so to speak one time
And so, you estimate
what your monthly travel is going to be--Do you have any idea what that's going to be
Um, well to start out, I'll be doing a lot of training
so I won't be traveling consistently for about six months
so I don't know what the monthly expenses will be
OK. Won't be much then.
But let's just use
Is it monthly that they reimburse?
Um, it's every pay check. Every two weeks
OK. All right. So really all we have to worry about is two week's worth of travel.
So let's pretend two weeks worth of travel was $1,000.
OK?
If you put $1000 in this checking account or
$1200 in the checking account
And you use your debit card.
And you use your money. You turn it in
They give you a check for $1000.
You put the $1000 back in this account
You see what I'm saying? You only have to put it in there one time. And you're using
your money but
they're reimbursing you which is what you're doing by the way
when you use a credit card.
-Yeah.
-I mean, what if they didn't pay you?
Well, you'd have credit card debt.
Well, you've lost the money.
Guess what? You've lost the money either way. That' s the weird thing
So I don't have anybody
on my team that I ask
to travel with their personal money.
-OK
-We always furnish the money
for them to travel
Either furnish them a debit card from our company
if they travel a lot. Or,
We advance them petty cash to pay for the travel
and we pay for the expenses. And they can't turn in anything
on that debit card obviously
or on that petty cash receipt that isn't
you know, I'm not buying their shampoo, OK? I'm not
buying a dress for you while you're on the road. That's your problem.
I'm talking about usable company expenses
for travel.
And uh, that's what you limit it to.
Be very, very careful that you don't use it for anything that isn't reimbursable
And then the money will always go right back to the account.
And the only thing you're at risk is two weeks
worth of travel.
And that works really well for people who travel a lot.
And the debit card by the way on the road will do everything
your credit card will do.
I've heard people say "Well it doesn't work
"internationally." Well I just returned from 3 weeks in Europe. I just got back.
I didn't have one single episode
Not one negative episode with my debit card.
Not one. Everyone took it.
Just like a credit card. Guess what? That's basically what it is.
Except it's using the money out of your account.
Hey guys thanks for watching! If you enjoyed this
video, click the subscribe button!
To get the latest content and clips from the show!